ciao mariners e benvenuti in uno vissi
mo.vi
idea benvenuti alla nuovissima puntata
di indovinano con musi se vi siete persi
le scorse puntate ovviamente vi
spiegherò brevemente di cosa si tratta
queste sono delle carte hanno due facce
fronte e retro davanti c'è un rettangolo
giallo dentro questo rettangolo giallo
ci sono delle musiche abbiamo quindi
trovare la parola la frase la canzone
l'artista faccio ovviamente riferimento
alle puntate precedenti per risolvere
appunto questo questa sorta di rebus con
le voci è arrivato il momento di
iniziare una nuova challenge quella
della travel edition trave liscio nel
senso che come appunto si può leggere
anche dietro
parliamo di bandiere di paesi di città
di monumenti
ovviamente non si può partecipare a una
challenge da soli e quindi ho bisogno di
qualcuno che giochi insieme e quel
qualcuno è per la prima volta su questo
canale non l'avete mai visto
edoardo ciao saluta il pubblico a casa
iniziamo subito ma vi dove guarda che è
il lupo perde il pelo ma non il vizio
ognuno di noi avrà a disposizione tre
aiuti
il primo è chiedere a un amico un
parente qualsiasi persona tramite chat
whatsapp di secondo è chiedere aiuto ai
nostri follower di instagram
il terzo è cambiare calcio e non online
on line non la riesco indovinare ho la
possibilità di prenderne un'altra chi
inizia per primo testo croce e cosa
facciamo
in testa a pari pari gli spari ok per
ogni 6 separi sono io se scegli story
sei tu che però sappiamo giocare bisogna
fare un pò così ben sette dispari mio
io credo che questo ciò che sarà molto
difficile ma entrambi si watch sibiu ma
che erode seaview vista mare morte vero
dio e vero che tutto in inglese
posso parlare
[Musica]
vai che bandiera i ragazzi ma che
bandiera si fa una tavoletta appunto è
un paese arabo
[Musica]
ti giuro sparato a carissimo chi è che
fortuna ea portiamo a casa ma tg1 ha
sparato a caso avete già grido per me
avrei avuto veramente fortuna da hugo
arrivare
è una cosa che trovi a bordo
e ancora comitato queste bag
devo dire che ho seguito fortunato per
adesso perché ti avvicini ma alla 66
niente 6 destinata a trovare tutte le
bandiere tu vai non è vero allora questa
la somma israele no argentina no dai
l'ala sapevo lo sapevo e argentina come
io lo sapevo perché motore non puoi
andare distinto devi essere ponderata
giappone japan cioè capito brasile
[Musica]
non scorderanno sento l'indizio cioè
inutile vai con la faccia e chimico
tengo molto famoso alla foresta
amazzonica foreste amazzoniche si
tradurrà cioè un'altra un altro nome
inglese dai è però che stanno certo
dobbiamo farlo in italiano c'è ma allora
mettiamo questa regola adesso che
possiamo dirla in italiano
e allora prendo io buttata io ho detto
forse siamo sempre al di là scusami a
questo anche in italia non è nemica
della bandiera quella è la bandiera
della australia ha sì sì sì sì quella
cosa lì australian opera usa
scusami non ho capito australia opera
now opera causa no eh sì ne ho per prima
cosa ma poi come ci sei arrivato
sento puzza di filetti aurelian opera
come sia arrivata la microfono all'opera
house c'è ma è perché famosa è la cosa
più famosa di simile portata in die
cos'è è facilissima facilissima che
cos'è las vegas
leona festa di tarantino partite
[Musica]
no dai facilissimo germania non è anche
più belle guerra aveva avuto anche tempo
di girarla dal verso giusto
di più in divisa
edoardo stai leggendo in trasfera che ho
peccato il pieno non lo so non triangle
triangle ci ha parlato di travel e
tonici triangle e ma questa mattina non
la conosce è giusto una bandiera così
che non conosce con un triangolo di
nuove cose di famiglia invece un tavolo
il triangolo nel mondo
il nord in un triangolo tutto nord è una
costruzione a dubai
[Musica]
dubai vivere le piramidi vai di dubai fa
o gravi che non ce ne sono dubai te lo
assicuro dai ma che palle
cioè si fa più facile canada bellissimo
se la pausa di quasi tre ore
che le bandiere i progetti posso dire
che in asia un utilizzo l'aiuto ma lei
questa tv avevano il continente
[Musica]
comunque quadro geografia edoardo 0 ma è
capito chi ha sempre comandato in
geografia nero senegal non è in europa
ok il portogallo solo bandiere comunque
ma veramente rotto le balle austria
dai cavolo mi hanno risposto mia sorella
che ignorante 6 quindi thailandia come
dire ci devo pensare un po forse dai
[Musica]
danni indizio
bella chiedono a chiederla chiedo perché
anche scusatevi anch'io il mio è mio
anche lei al suo aiuto quindi la paura
di sbagliare come si sa chi è
[Musica]
honey moon a me tutte le bandiere le
cose mie parole la tour eiffel dai
questa casa bianca time no time times
square duty free
sì dai
malesia
vabbè promuovo un aiuto a un aiuto ok
allora i gay paolo velocissimi hanno
detto sudafrica ci ha appena pubblicato
è morta
sì però è giusto io mi ribello a questa
cosa che del tai ragazzi obiettivamente
facile facile l'isola di pasqua bagaglio
a mano dai ragazzi però romania 20 cat
ticket referenti che abbia l'intero ardo
facciamola fondo dobbiamo contare ai
ragazzi vogliamo forse contare 123 17 di
poco sono stata sfortunata in situ però
io voglio santo di una cosa il qatar con
il catania ho vinto cia tutta la partita
perché c'è chi è che rendo via va beh
non so che dire non so che dire perché
speravo di vincere perché è il travel è
una cosa che mi interessa amo e cioè c'è
l'estate si avvicina quindi sento
percepisco proprio il driver che mi si
avvicina e quindi un attimo un piccolo r
cup perché nella prima abbiamo sarei già
aveva gareggiato nella seconda vittore
disparati musica e adesso viaggio
ovviamente ovviamente perché c'è dopo
vince io cosa vinto edoardo una scarpa
col tacco con il pelo rosa
la lite è arrivato da poco
pronta per halloween ma che faccio
salutiamo i nostri veri ne grazie per
averci seguito ci vediamo alla prossima
puntata di indovinano con me moggi ad
oronzo
[Musica]